yo if you'd like to support me in this
channel move University and creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
on my website move University comm thank
you and enjoy the video so in this video
enzyme inhibition uncompetitive
inhibitors
I've yet to actually talk about these
okay so same idea generally enzyme plus
substrate gives you enzyme substrate
complex which gives you an Zion product
now what about an uncompetitive
inhibitor we saw that competitive
inhibitors buying at the active site
non-competitive inhibitors bind
somewhere other than the active site now
with uncompetitive members where exactly
do they bind well I'm not exactly sure
about that but what I do know is about
what it is they bind to so the enzyme
and substrate you have to come together
right the substrate binds the active
site and then forms the enzyme substrate
complex now the the uncompetitive
inhibitor iuc binds only to the enzyme
substrate complex the enzyme loops the
enzyme substrate complex it does not
bind to free enzyme it beads it needs a
substrate to have already bound the
enzyme so the uncompetitive inhibitor
binds only to the enzyme substrate
complex we solve that competitive
inhibitors bind the free enzyme and the
non-competitive inhibitors combine the
free enzyme or the enzyme substrate
complex but uncompetitive inhibitors
require the substrate to have bound the
enzyme in order for them to bind
so once the enzyme substrate complex
forms the uncompetitive inhibitor can
come in and bind so I've kind of drawn
it here in in this weird shape so that
you can kind of see that that's got this
little kind of like indentation right
here right the reason I put that there
is so that you can imagine that this
substrate needs to have bound here and
then the uncompetitive hitter can only
bind what's that you know once it can
fit there with the enzyme and substrate
that's at least how I imagined it anyway
now that this enzyme substrate inhibitor
complex is formed that cannot progress
towards enzyme and product
okay so that's kind of the idea with
uncompetitive inhibitors as far as the
pictures go now how does that look here
okay so we just said that the enzyme has
to bind the substrate and form the
enzyme substrate complex before the
uncompetitive inhibitor can come in so
if you just have free enzyme and
uncompetitive inhibitor that's not going
to bind it do anything so once you have
that enzyme substrate complex the
inhibitor or the uncompetitive inhibitor
can come in form the enzyme substrate
inhibitor complex which like I said
cannot progress towards the enzyme and
product okay so now this this process
right here this uncompetitive inhibitor
actually coming in and binding this
enzyme substrate complex is pretty
important why is that well when it does
this it depletes the amount of the
enzyme substrate complex right and what
that does is that that of course this is
an equilibrium here right between the
enzyme plus substrate to enzyme
substrate complex and backwards reaction
a there that's an equilibrium and what
this does right what this process does
adding this uncompetitive inhibitor is
it depletes the amount of enzyme
substrate complex which shifts the
equilibrium of A's reaction to to
produce more enzyme substrate so it
shifts reaction AZ equilibrium towards
the enzyme substrate complex I towards
the right and what this does is this
means that more enzyme and substrate
will come together bind each other to
make that it's I'm substrate complex
right to account for that loss so what
this is what this sort of triggers is a
seemingly higher affinity of this enzyme
for the substrate right the enzyme
substrate you're going to seem to bind
more often to form the enzyme substrate
complex so this means that a lower
substrate concentration is required to
reach the v-max which means we have a
lower km right higher affinity lower km
now the reverse process here is
important so I've drawn it this
equilibrium arrow going from the enzyme
substrate inhibitor complex back up to
the enzyme substrate complex and I want
to comment on that because even though
this enzyme substrate inhibitor complex
can dissociate back into the enzyme
substrate complex and free uncompetitive
inhibitor there will still be some
enzyme substrate inhibitor complex
uncompetitive inhibitor complex which
means that we'll have less reactions
catalyzed per unit time then we would
without that inhibitor right so we end
up having a decreased v-max right that
that should make sense so even though
this enzyme substrate inhibitor complex
can dissociate back in tannins I'm
substrate complex there there's still
going to be some of it around which is
which is taking away from the optimal
velocity at which this enzyme substrate
complex could convert you know the
substrate into product so the v-max will
will be decreased so I have a decreased
v-max and a decreased km so how would
that look on the hyperbolic graph
well again the yellow line is the line
with no inhibitor and the pink one is
with an uncompetitive and Emperor so the
v-max with the yellow line is up here
and I've drawn the v-max of the pink
line to be at so the pink v-max is that
50 as opposed to a hundred for the
uninhibited reaction and so the the
v-max decreased by a factor of two right
it was divided in half so it decreased
by a factor of two right hundred divided
by two you get 50 now
is the km for the for the uninhibited
reaction well at the v-max over two in
yellow that would be 100 divided by 2
which is 50 and the km is out here add
half the v-max the substrate
concentration at half the v-max is right
there but for the pink one the v-max is
at 50 so the v-max over 2 is at 25 and
the km is here now I didn't give values
for these substrate concentrations here
but this km this original km going to
this km apparent here it's also
decreasing by a factor of 2 so as a
decrease by a factor of 2 as well they
are both decreasing by the same factor
now again they don't have to decrease by
that by a factor of 2 they can decrease
by another factor but the point is that
the factor by which they do decrease
will be equal for both the v-max and the
km how does that translate into the
lineweaver-burk plot well now if we look
at this yellow line uninhibited yellow
line we've got an x intercept here x
intercept we'll call this x intercept 1
and we've got a different x intercept on
the uncompetitive inhibitor graph right
so we'll call that X in it x intercept 2
we also change the y intercept here so
here we got y intercept one for the not
inhibited and then for the inhibited one
will have y intercept 2 so why is this
well let's look at the y intercept y is
1 over the v-max or see me the y
intercept is 1 over V Max so V Max
decreased V Max decreased so we're
dividing by a smaller number when it
comes to finding that y-intercept so the
y-intercept is larger which is why we
have a higher y-intercept
okay so that's that accounts for that
and the x-intercept was initially here
but it shifted out over here to the left
why is that well we said the km
decreased so x-intercept is equal to
negative one over the km km decreased
we're dividing also again by a smaller
number so the x-intercept is going to be
larger in magnitude which is why it's
further out further away from zero so
that's why that's why this shift
occurred here all right now what you'll
notice is that what happened to the
slope here right the slope the slope is
the km over the v-max so the km
decreased by a factor of two according
to our our there are hyperbolic sort of
graph and the v-max also decreased by a
factor of two and because they're both
decreasing and by the same factor the
slope isn't change the slope remains
unchanged the slope remains unchanged it
remains the same so these lines these
lines then are parallel right because
they have different intercepts but they
have the same slope so they are parallel
lines so the inhibited reaction is just
shifted up on the on the y intercept
into the left on the x intercept but the
slope of the lines are identical now my
lines aren't perfect but they do
represent parallel lines I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
yo if you found that video helpful then
please be sure to LIKE comment and
subscribe for more content and if you
know what I believe you might find this
video helpful then please be sure to
share it with them thank you and happy
studying